вечір на думській триває ми говоримо про
цікаве та актуальне і в цій студії для
вас працюють Роман Семенов і Тетяна
блайда і у цій годині ми будемо говорити
про Україну про те що відбувається в
Україні поговоримо про Одесу і раді
вітати в цій годині в цій студії
почесного гостя Петра Порошенка п'ятого
президента України Петро Олексійович
вітаємо вітаємо вас Петро олексійовичу
Дякую що долучилися до нашої розмови
знайшли час ну ми знаємо що стало
причиною вашого візиту по-перше це
прощання з українським художником з
найкращим мабуть директором Одеського
художнього музею Олександром ройбуртом
мені хочеться запитати відразу як ви
його запам'ятали і ким ви його знали
політичним діячем художником обличчям
патріотичної Одеси ким він для вас є і
залишається по-перше е з одного боку
Олександр ройбурт -
це людина дуже близька до мене до нашої
родини до нашого кола до нашої
політичної партії до метціва по-друге це
людина яка власність світу масштаб
особистості постаті Олександра Роберта Я
думаю що лише тільки через декілька
років буде зрозумілий тим хто були поруч
з ним бо це є безсумнів великий художник
художник який випередив свій час і
звичайно не всім подобається його
картини Але я маю тверде переконання і
тверду теорію це тому що він був
настільки сучасним настільки проривним
настільки
креативним що це просто треба працювати
над собою щоб почати розуміти те що цей
митець хотів сказати в світі його
оцінили і багатьох музеях світу є його
картини і вони визнані так на похованні
були виступи дуже багатьох із знаних
особистості Мені дуже сподобалось що
якщо X століття в Одесі було епохою
кастандії то 20-2 століття Це точно
назвуть епохою Олександра ройбурта А нам
з вами в майбутніх підручниках історії
доведеться згадка про нас що ми жили в
епоху Олександра ройбурта крім цього Це
був великий менеджер бо я думаю що каж
казали що пощастило Олександру що його
призначили на посаду директора музею Я
маю абсолютну протилежну думку що Одесі
і Україні і нам всім пощастило що
Олександр взявся за цю дуже благородну
справу Петро олексівичу Як ви думаєте що
буде з одеським художнім музеєм без
Олександра ройборта І чи політичні
опоненти про яких ми з вами знаємо які
вели боротьбу за музей чи вони не
повернеться і Чи музей не змінться через
Отакі перестановки слухайте нас більше
людей які люблять Олександра людей які
розуміють творчість людей які люблять
Одесу і людей Бо що таке музей При
ройбурті Якщо хочете це безвіз для Одеси
тільки в'їзд в Одесу Бо велика кількість
іноземних гостей приїжджали в Одесу саме
на ройбурта і якщо ми будемо
продовжувати цю справу і будемо казати
що в Одесі крім величезної кількості
атракцій які ви зможете подивитися ви
будете ще мати доступ до великого
містецтва до я приклав руку Олександр
ройбурт це вже наш борг перед Україною
перед Одесою це зберегти і я тому дуже
Вітаю ініціативу депутатів нашої фракції
фракції європейської солідарності і в
міській раді і в обласній раді е ми
повністю підтримуємо ініціативу Олексія
Гончаренка який е запропонував з позицію
партії про те що ми маємо перейменувати
музей назвати його на честь Олександра
ройборта і я думаю що і вдячні одесити
це буде правильна реакція якщо на його
ім'я буде перейменовано одли бу ми
знаємо що була ініціатива про
перейменування однієї з вулиць Одеси Да
я ж кажу однієї з вулиць Одеси е
переходячи вже до розмови більш поточної
мається на увазі про те що відбувається
безпосередньо в Україні які є проблеми
економічні політичні знаєте є така
приказка що давняукраїнська що дрова
назииму готують з літа тому хочеться
запитати вас про те А можна перед цим я
скажу буквально декілька слів про
Олександра будласка от Ми всі маємо свою
історію про Олександра Марина яка не
змогла сьогодні бути разом зі мною разом
з ним разом з Дмитром шивківим готувала
законодавство про український культурний
фонд і так як Олександр цьому віддавався
то величезна заслуга в тому що він був
створений і він був саме таким коли
митці отримували від нього по прозорій
моделі фінансування це теж внесок в тому
числі Олександра ройбурта і ті що на
сьогоднішній день прийшли для того щоб
віддати шану а їх були сотні людей і за
ті слова які вони висловили на підтримку
Олександра на підтримку нам це я хотів
просто подякувати всім хто
це дивився Хто там був присутній
подякувати що ви прийшли і подякувайти
за те що ви зберігаєте таким пам'ять про
так Одеса сумує за Олександром ройбуртом
і вся Україна сумує мабуть Ну а ми
рухаємось далі так панове повертаючись
до мого питання яке я почав уже ставити
вам щодо тарифів це дуже така мабуть
поряд із коронавірусом тарифи - це така
тема яка болюча для багатьох українців
бачимо що зараз відбувається з тарифами
на електроенергію на газ на тепло на
воду що скажете з цього приводу і як
взагалі захистити людей Від різкого
здорощення ко Ну по-перше ще не болюче
коли в Одесі Плю 30 тарифи на тепло
ніхто не думає А у нас вже думають Петро
вже думаю А коли прийде осінь то влада
яка обіцяла твердо що вони знижуть
тарифи рівно в два
рази замість цього їх підняли більше ніж
в два рази Оце є
класична зразок відповідальності країни
за те що вона повірила по популістам і
некомпетентним людям вони прийшли до
влади на тому що вони обіцяли що
закінчиться епоха бідності а насправді
закінчили епоху гідності вони прийшли на
тому що вони підвищають заробітну платню
а насправді з урахуванням інфляції
купівельна спроможність кожної
української родини різко впала і ви цим
можете переконатися просто на полицях
крамниць коли ви платите на 50% за
дорожче за за найбільш необхідні
продукти харчування і зараз по тарифам
Вони обіцяли знизити в два рази вони
підняли в два рази що ми робили свого
часу коли використовували таке знаєте
дуже складне для вуха слово
субсидіарност і субсидії але це дуже
просто люди найменш захінщені верстви
населення яким не вистачає грошей на
сплату житлово-комунальних тарифів
обов'язково за дуже простою процедурою
від держави отримують субсидію
компенсацію
і вони не витрачають більше
10-15% на сплату житловокомунальних
послуг яких би не ска вона не була що з
причому для цього не треба було ніяких
документів паперовиї волокити ти просто
даєш заявку і тобі виділяють гроші до
цього були долучені 7 млн
домогосподарств України це величезна
кількість зараз замість 7 млнів у них
залишилось менше 3 млн 4 млн залишились
сам насам своїми проблемами
зараз Кошти які були передбачені на
субсидія вони їх скоротили більш ніж два
рази Бо їм треба красти
і за ці скорочені кошти вони вже
використані на
85-90% А чим робити другу половину року
Це не ваші проблеми на кого вони хотіли
передати відповідальність передати
відповідальність Вони хотіли на місцеві
органи влади неха нехай Мери
відповідають це ще й руйнує
децентралізацію А тепер правильно ви
задавати питання Що роби нап
опалювальнийонце болюче тання по-перше
потрібно мати компетентну владу влада
яка буде знати що робити ми готові
підставити плаче ми готові підсказати ми
готові поділитися опитом не просто це
пустозвоне А це те що ми робили з 14го
по 19 рік різко збільшити кошти на
субсидії позиція перша позиція друга
перейти на це ж ми забезпечили імпорт
газу з Європи це ми поставили край
російському шантажу е кожний Жовтень
Україна починала з звинувачення Росії в
тем що ми крадемо газ із перекриттям під
йолочку під ялинку ее постачання газу
нам треба енергетична безпека Європи для
цього ми підписали енергетичну картію
Energy communityтт для цього ми
забезпечили підтримку Європейського
Союзу і нам треба щоби в балансі
Європейського Союзу доля Росії газу не
перевищувала 30% і решт доповнювалося
іншими джерелами і тоді Росія буде
позбавлена права шантажувати хтось хотів
не хтось А пан Зеленський хотів
подивитися пану Путіну в очі хотів
знайти там не тільки щоб припинити
стріляти не тільки мир а ще і дешевий
газ і що ж ви там надивилися за 2 з по
роки коли по 500 доларів українець буде
платити за кожну тися кубометрів газу і
і Я переконаний що ми сформували проект
рішень які захистять людей Бо ключове
слово бідна людина має бути захищена
державаю для цього існує держава а не
для того щоби обкрадати платника
податків чим зараз займається Зелена
влада і для цього треба відійти від
популізму і для цього треба мати
компетентних керівників Ні того ні
другого немає є ще одне болюче питання
до речі ви вже підняли тему пода
податкову так знаємо що Одеса - це місто
середнього малого бізнесу і зараз дуже
багато людей дивляться на законодавчі
ініціативи влади наприклад закон 5600
там йдеться про добровільне декларування
там йдеться про податок на витрати Як ви
ставитесь до цих ініціатив і не чи
складається враження що влада хоче
наповнити бюджет або врятувати ситуацію
за рахунок саме малого та середнього
бізнесу дивіться Влада не рятує ситуацію
ее в тому числі за рахунок одеситів
простих людей чи малого та середнього
бізнесу влади гроші є вони їх просто
крадуть приклад от Подивіться Зараз ми
святкуємо 30тиріччя української
незалежності я як президент е брав
участь в підготовці
ее багатьох е військових парадів і
святкування незалежності найдіть мені в
бюджеті одну копійку коли Ми забрали з
коштів платників податків того щоб
влаштовувати свято Ви її не знайдете ні
для Міністерства оборони підготовки
військового параду ні для інших заходів
це було зроблено Таким чином щоби не
обкрадати людей 5 млрд грн з кишень
платників податків було витрачено на
корпоративчики 95-го кварталу для того
щоб вони святкували 30-ту річницю
незалежності 30-ту річницю незалежності
треба в першу чергу святкувати рівнем
життя людей друга позиція коли ми
забирає коли ми вони обговорюємо їх
законопроект Ми Точно за нього не будемо
голосувати але ми зробимо все можливе
для того щоб він не прийшов бо це
погіршення е умов малого та середнього
бізнеса хто працює на спрощеній системі
оподаткування перше це є уявить собі що
всі хто зараз будуть хотіти придбати
квартиру чи житло на які вони копичили
десятками років Зараз будуть платити на
20% більше у вигляді податків це що
означає що у нас люди такі заможні що у
нас молоде покоління яке вступає в життя
і через іпотеку розраховувало купити
собі квартиру перше житло зараз має з їх
кишень витягати додаткових 20% тому що
це Зелена сволота ще не не жерлася і
третя ініціатива яка вийшла Лише зараз і
вона за межами законопроекту 5600
це взагалі знущання над українським
народом Вони збираються ввести податки
на видатки якщо проста людина вирішила е
щось витратити то омріяне паном
Зеленським поліцейська держава має
можливість постучати не к олігарху
коломойському не к корупціонеру міністру
а к простій людині і спитати а я
перепрошую Ну вони кажуть про те що якщо
людина не може пояснити джерело цих
доходів які вона витрачає наприклад на
нову квартиру або нову машину То в тому
випадку
В мене прохання не вірте їм в нас є
Конституція і по Конституції у нас є
презумпція невинуватості
презумпція невинуватості це є що кожен
громадянин до того часу коли через суд
не буде доведена його вина є
невиновни вони кажуть що це ти маєш мені
пояснити А де ти взяв гроші а ми це тобі
повіримо чи не повіримо і це означає що
кожного підприємст кожного платника
податків і кожного громадянина Вони
намагаються підвишити нагачок хто так
робив диктатори для чого Бо друзям все
ворогам закон от вони приймають такий
закон що можуть зайти в дом до кожного і
сказати ну-ка Поясни мені джерело
походження то ось в мене довідки Все я
вам не вірю порушуємо кримінальну справу
і в'язницю або якщо не хочеш іти в
в'язницю 18% ти заплатиш за оцінку
всього що ти маєш це в умовах бідної
країни Я вважаю що це
стовідсоткове знущання натутниками
податків не там панові зелені слуги ви
шукаєте гроші Петро олексівич Як вам
законодавчі ініціативи щодо олігархів що
за закон до олігархів це дієвий спосіб
аби
подолати таку кризу яка у нас склася в
Україні 100% і це правильне питання
подняте ми його повністю підтримуємо
тільки закон який внесе паном Зеленським
не має до боротьби з олігархами ніякого
відношення наша фракція розробила і
подала закон де ми боремося з справжніми
олігархами які є монополістами щоб вони
не монополізовували ринок яки Є Не є
платниками податків які виводять гроші
через фінансові потоки через офшори і
які головне належать до влади бо Олігарх
з грецькою - це влада небагатьох
влада і тоді коли
Зеленський все своє оточення яке краде
на великому крадівництві яке краде на
ковідному фонді яке краде на державних
підприємствах які краде на виведення з
державних закупівель які нами були
створен і справляє десятки або сотні
мільярдів гривень на корупційну складову
це не є олігархи а закон який він
намагається використати має дві мети
перша - це бороть
для того щоби конфіскувати засоби
масової інформації завтра олігархам
будуть оголошені всі власники незалежних
медіа це 100% це антиконституційна
позиція коли через санкції проти людей
які не подобаються пану зеленському без
суду без слідчо органів без
конституційних прав і свобод громадян
будуть прийматися рішення про вилучення
тих чи інших засобів масової інформації
і друга позиція це є переслідування ці
тому якщо ми боремося з олігархами наша
політична сила запропонувала абсолютно
прозорий базуючийся на Європейському
американському досвіді отриманий і
підтриманий міжнародними експертами вони
не хочуть це розглядати вони хочуть
розглядати позицію яка перетворює
Україну з демократичної держави на
авторитарний режим на кшталт Лукашенко
Петро Олексійович ще одна тема оце вже
не економічна а медична коронавірус
начебто вже йде на спад начебто вжей
багато є вакцин але темпи вакцинації Як
то кажуть викликають питання що скажете
з цього приводу і які Висновки та уроки
варто було б зробити Я хочу сказати що
влади України боротьба з коронавірусом
була повністю провалена і ціна яку за це
заплатили
українці
величезно якщо ви
подивитесь навколо
себе то зараз кожна родина має дуже
близьку
людину яка померла від ковіда або
від ускладнень які були їм викликані До
речі і Олександр ройбруд перехворів
ковідом Євген Марчук якого ми ховали
нещодавно також мав ковід Ну і більшість
людей молодо молодого віку все 150 000
українців віддали своє життя
150 тисяч за Дани Національної академії
наук були за віддали життя внаслідок
того того що вони не отримали своєчасну
вакцинацію і не отримали своєчасне
лікування і були позбавлені елементарної
медичної допомоги включно з кисневою
допомогою в чому найбільша помилка влади
в плані боротьби з коронавірусоум тому
що кошти з коронавірусу Які ми
перенаправили ще в березні 20-го року в
самому початку ковіду коли треба було
тоді заплатити невеличку кошти
попередньої оплати першого внеску за
вакцини і ми би їх отримали вже в другій
половині 20-го року в другій половині а
так вони До січня не отримали Нічого До
січня 21 року і аж до того як вони
відновили співпрацю з тою компанією яку
Ми найшли е під час ее медичної реформи
пам'ятаєте була програма доступні ліки і
програма кро компанія Crown Agent яка
допомагала нам купувати серцево-судинні
противоонкологічні і інші антидіабетичні
препарати зараз менше ніж за місяць
найшла І привезла а до цього Зелена
Влада требувала відкати від виробників
вакцин для того щоб вони поза системою
державних закупівель
prozoro спілкувалися з ними аж допоки
всі виробники вакцин відмовилися з ними
співпрацювати
крім ковішилда індійського який
зараз поки що не визнається для видачі
сертифікатї для поїздок в більшість
країн і лише Crown Agent лише наші
іноземні партнери і міжнародні
організації від яких вони відмовилися
тому що вони співпрацювали з командою
Порошенка вони забезпечили і йer вони
забезпечили і закупівлю модерни вони
забезпечили і
найсучасніші ліки включно з майбутніми
Джонсон Джонсон разовими
вакцинами дати
п'ять доказів цього тобто на
сьогоднішній день левови в середньому
Європейський союз вже провакцинував
більше
50%. 50 у нас таких цифр немає а у нас
Вони провакцинували менше 4%. От і це
тоді коли в дефіциту вакцин в світі вже
немає коли всі хто хотів
провакцинувався да І на сьогоднішній
день треба було робити правильну
кампанію щодо роз'яснення вакцинування
роз'яснення вакцинування це є те коли
лікарі не
Аферисти які незаконни поза чергою з
наближених
державо влади Зеленського структур офіс
президента там всякі неподрби і всякі
радники їхні отримали в першу чергу а я
вакцинувався вже тоді коли важко
перехворів вакцинувався лише в липні
місяці коли дійшла черга в сімейного
доктора яку вакцину обрали для себе які
довірились це було б фйзер але тоді коли
це було в липні ее зараз скільки там
менше місяця тому і зараз коли вже нема
дефіциту і я хочу сказати що ми робили
все можливе вся партія весь центральний
апарат ми запросили тіх хто хотів
вакцинуватися їх було майже 100% партії
і ми робили все можливе для того щоби
власним прикладом демонструвати що
вакцинуватися треба Пет і найгірше
Попереду ще одна і вірус Дельти
починаючи з другої половини вересня в
жовтні очікувати спала хонового Восени
ми Очікуємо на нього чи готові ви для
того аби щось продемонструвати проти
вірусу дельф ті хто не зробив щеплення
то стовідсотково підвергає ризику не
лише себе а всіх оточуючих Отже
вакцинуватися треба є ще однаваливате
і підготувати нарешті ліжковий фонд для
того щоби сприйняти той удар який весени
можна нанести вірус Дельта Петре
олексійовичу давайте переходити Далі ви
нещодавно написали для польської газети
аналітичну статтю де розбили по паличках
меседжі Володимира Путіна про те що
українці і росіяни один народ Що слід
взяти з цієї статті українцям аби
замислитись І взагалі чи з'явиться вона
в українських джерелах бо в польських
так газетах вона вже є вона набуло Я був
здивований але вона на бууло дуже
широкого розголосу в
світі достатньо сказати що найбільш
популярна польська газета Виборча
віддала цьому
декілька сторінок і кількість звернень в
тому числі в інтернеті була рекордна
передрукували її в великій кількості
країн Європи і мені приємно що вона була
перекладена і українською мовою і ті хто
хотів мав можливість до неї долучитися
стаття не про
історію бо я Незважаючи на всі свої
червоні дипломи і там відмінні оцінки по
історії не є
істориком стаття про
безпеку надзвичайно не точніше про
небезпеку яка загрожує нам з боку Росії
я про це говорив багато років сьогодні
це не треба применшувати небезпеку цієї
статті це я порів паралели як ма
моя боротьба Гітлера це як заява я був
присутній в 2007 році на мюнхенській
безпековій конференції заява пана Путіна
яка
передувала збройні агресії проти
суверенної незалежної Грузії там
говориться не про те що ми один народ
хоча насправді там підводиться до цього
що українці з росіянами один народ але
українці другого сорту Петро олесвич і
друга позиція це засвідчений факт що
Росія має територіальні претензії до
України що робити з тими українцями які
погоджуються з цією позицією Путіна ми ж
всі знаємо це
нашуміли результати дослідження
соціологічної групи рейтинг 41%
погоджується з твердженням Путіна Як
бути в цій ситуації по-перше Я теж хочу
щоб ми уникли уникли маніпуляцій у нас
91% українців підтримують суверенітет і
територіальну цілісність України у нас
приблизно така більше 90% засуджують
рішучу російську військову агресію і
якщо Це божевілля вже коли агресор
прийшов до тебе додому а ти кажеш що це
брати вони вдерлися згвалтували твою
дружину вбили твоїх дітей а ти аналізуєш
як їх зустрічати з караваєм чи з квасом
позиція одна в першу чергу захистить
свою землю бо Ніхто крім нас її не
захистить позиція одна збережить Україну
позиція одна звільнить від загарбників
від агресора кожен клаптик української
землі а коли Україна відновить Свій
суверенітет ми тоді поговоримо про
формат співпраці з Росією і позиція
третя збережить демократію не дайте
Путіну
перетворити Україну в федеральний округ
Російської імперії з з відсутністю
прямих виборів з відсутністю свободи
слова з відсутністю захисту конційних
прав і свобод громадян те що ми зараз
бачимо На жаль перші кроки цього
робиться в Україні Україна стоїть на
позі 30 років
Незалежності як по-вашому на вашу думку
які роки були найскладнішими в нашій
історії найвизначальнішими в нашій
історії що ви б побажали українцям
напередодні цієї дати Україна об'єктив
во мала непрості всі 30
років Україна мала протягом цих 30тирічч
не лише поразки але великечезну
кількість
досягнень звичайно що я в період з 14-го
по 19-й рік був найбільш проінформованою
людиною щодо викликів щодо загроз і щодо
досягнень які ми набули і тому в 14-му
році коли я був обраний президентом був
захоплений весь Донбас
весь на рахунку в казначействі було 108
000 грн
ль в Україні не було армії від слова
зовсім в мене в резерві не було жодного
батальйону то мобілізацію яку ми зробили
в Україні не було озброєння техніки вона
вся була розкрадена без акумуляторів без
засобів зв'язку без палива без без
двигунів без карбюраторів без нічого Це
була цереспрямована позиція знищення
держави і те що була оголошена
мобілізація те що волонтери стали на
захист те що держава і народ віддали
останнє для того щоби дати нам видохнути
два-три місяці поки ми зберемо з усього
світу Те чим
захищатися Звичайно що і ми говоримо не
лише про армію яку ми створили ми
говоримо не лише про мову бо Мова - це
не тільки українська мова ройтбут
Олександр і його Мистецтво - це про мову
бо це про культуру нова українська школа
- це про мову про культуру український
культурний фонд - це про мову квоти на
телебачення радіомовлення Коли нарешті
говорити українською стала драйвово
кайфово модно круто в тому числі і серед
молоді це те що відбулося за останні пть
років при тому що ніхто не обмежував
права російськомовних українців бо я
народився в місті Белград Одеській
області мої батьки з ізмаїла і в
бісарабії Ну тільки в селі говорили на
суржику А так російська мова була і
зараз залишається дуже розповсюджено і
для мене це аж ніяк не заважало коли я
ні одного дня не вивчав українськую мову
ні в школі ні ні в університеті бо я
навчався на факультеті міжнародних
відносин тоді там українська була засть
для мене сьогодні російськомовного
українця комфортніше спілкуватися
українською мовою якщо я це зробив то це
може зробити кожен і в цих умовах але це
ще й
безвіз всі говорили про те що безвіз це
лише для заможних людей які можуть
поїхати там Відень чи Болгарію чи ні
безвіз я про це кажу Вперше це в тому
числі мотивація для українських
роботодавців піднімати середню заробітну
платню для того щоби конкурувати з
поляками чехами болгарами і румунами і у
нас на сьогоднішній
день правду
сказавро сгоднішній день випереджаючими
темпами за 5пть років мого президентства
зростала середня заробітна платня в три
рази був збільшений державний бюджет в
три рази за рахунок того що корупційні
фінансові потоки були перенаправлені в
бюджет 4 млрд доларів Ми забрали в
російського газпрому пвто мільрда
доларів Ми забрали в Януковича на ці
побудували дороги побудували військові
гуртожитки в тому
числі не за рахунок того що ми обдирали
Як ліпку малий та середній клас як вони
роблять зараз не за рахунок того щоб
вони набивали кишені на великому
крадівництві А за рахунок того що я
запровадив в Одесі дуже цікавий
експеримент я сказав що всі перевищення
планових надходжень Одеської митниці
залишаються в Одесі на будівництві
дороги одеса-рені лише тиждень тому я
мавав можливість проїхати по трасі Одеса
Рені подивитися І хочу сказати що з
платників податків ніхто не зняв не
копійки а експеримент спрацював не
тільки в Одеській але потім і у
Львівській Тернопільській Харківській і
в багатьох областях України Я дуже дякую
за те що програму будівництва доріг Ми
почали і вони тоді коштували вдвічіні
дешевше ніж зараз на великому
крадівництві Зеленського Петро
олексійовичу Ми вам дуже вдячні за те що
знайшли час долучилися до нашої розмови
я Нагадую телеглядачам що у нас в ефірі
був Петро Порошенко п'ятий президент
України ми говорили про політичну та
економічну ситуацію в Україні про
боротьбу з коронавірусом про малий та
середній бізнес ми ж свою чергу Бажаємо
вам міцного здоров'я гарного настрою і
нагадуємо що зустрінемось у цій студії
завтра о
[музика]
14:10